you've made some great videos to help
people learn what do you do with them
I'm Eddie Wu and I teach high school
mathematics in Sydney Australia in 2012
I started putting videos of my everyday
classroom teaching online and in this
video I'm gonna show you how to do the
same
we'll cover making a channel uploading
content and organizing it so it's easier
for people to use and to make a youtube
channel you'll need a Google account if
you already have a personal one I'd
encourage you to make a separate one for
your educational content some schools
and other education organizations like
mine use Google services and so you
might already have a school-based Google
account ready to go click on your
profile up in the top right then go
ahead and create a channel follow the
prompts and before long you'll have your
very own home on YouTube speaking of
which one of the first things you can do
is make it feel a bit more like home
upload a profile picture you like and
find a large wide image to put in place
as your channels header we're about to
upload your first video but before we do
that it's a good idea to go and make
some small changes to your upload
defaults every video on YouTube has
certain information like the title which
helps people find content when they go
searching well when they're watching
similar videos and two of the most
important pieces of information are the
video description and the videos tags
which tell YouTube what topics your
video is connected to back when I
started on YouTube I uploaded dozens of
videos onto my channel before I really
paid attention to these and when I did I
found it kind of cumbersome and
time-consuming to put in similar
information for every single video I put
up especially because I posted so many
videos upload defaults are exactly what
they sound like
we can put some generally relevant
information in here and they'll appear
by default on every video you put up to
edit these upload defaults go from your
channel into YouTube studio find the
settings option and then upload defaults
will be one of the subsections
and some useful information in here and
it'll save you having to put it in over
and over again
each time you upload now it's time to
put up your first video the upload
button can be found near the top right
of the page find the video file in your
computer and is selected to begin the
upload process and give your video a
title that's as succinct as possible but
still gives a helpful description
about the videos content you'll also
notice that the description and tags
have already been filled in with what we
put into the upload defaults but you can
add or change any details that seem
relevant to this video upload speeds
obviously vary widely depending on what
your internet connection is like and how
large your video file is I tend to let
my videos upload in the background while
I get other work done just remember you
have enough power and stay within range
of internet access once your videos
uploaded to YouTube their servers take
over and begin processing your file
again the length of this process varies
depending on how long your video is what
quality is how busy YouTube is with the
hundreds of hours of other content
that's being uploaded every minute of
the day the upload page will let you
know what's processing is finished at
this point your video is ready to go
live but before you do there are a
couple of final things to look out for
first now the video is processed you can
see the thumbnail has been automatically
created from one of the frames in the
video YouTube always gives you three
options to choose from if you don't like
that first one alternatively you can
make your own thumbnail image to upload
and this is often the primary thing that
grabs people's attention when they're
choosing something to watch
personally I don't do this because I
upload too often and if other priorities
for my time but pretty much every
serious YouTube out there puts a lot of
effort into this so I want you to be
aware of how it's done you can always
change this image later if you like the
other thing to keep in mind is
scheduling you can publish a video
immediately or set it to become visible
at a certain time I do this so that my
videos come out at regular intervals
rather than all at once when I squeeze
some time in for editing you may also
want to do this so that students can log
in and watch at a given time for a task
you want them to work on let's make this
one live right now if you head back to
your channels homepage you should see
your brand-new shiny video ready to go
I'd only suggest one more thing for you
at this point which is to consider
adding your video to a playlist this way
you can organize all the videos that
relate to a particular teaching topic
into one place I know this won't seem
all that relevant when you have just a
handful of videos on your channel but
one day you might have a few thousand
and you don't really want to make people
dig through those videos in reverse
chronological order to find the one that
they need
that's it we've covered recording
equipment basic shooting and editing
principles and now you know how to get
onto YouTube and share your videos with
the world now remember watching videos
alone is no substitute for the full
experience of learning with others in an
interactive way from a trained teacher
but if there's one thing I've learned
over the last few years of having my
channel videos can be an enormous leap
our fillet to support student learning
by leveraging all the knowledge and
experience of a skilled educator and
putting that in the hands of students I
hope you found these videos helpful and
they encourage you to kickstart your own
journey in creating a truly global
classroom